I should be live this is a gonna be a
completely new stream for me
I'm not only chess I'm on chess calm and
I'll be commentating for the next two
two and a half hours it's a protest
League the Webster windmills are playing
Minnesota blizzard thankfully I'm not
playing in this match I played once for
the windows a couple weeks ago and it
was messy so hopefully it'll be more fun
commentating watching the games we have
a very strong line-up this week we have
Lynn lay on board wine who's around top
20 in the world if I'm not mistaken uh
and then we have Tomas buhdeuce who's
like 26 50 feet a we have Ashwin Jayram
who has been performing very well in the
league so far I think he's won something
like nine out of 12 games and he has
like a performance rating of over 2700
so far this season so hopefully he'll
keep it up and then we have Katherina
Katherina nem silva on board for who we
kind of had to recruit at the last
minute because a lot of people were
unavailable to play but whole facial
rack in some points I think she'll be
out rated every match but we'll see how
it goes a game should be starting any
minute now currently on the Eric Hanson
game I was afraid this was gonna happen
with OBS
give me one moment there will be some
technical issues here exit out of that
game so two games have started I'm not
entirely sure why it did that
but that's how I learned let's make this
visible so around one we have and
rooting against Ashwin Jayram which i
think is a key matchup and routing is
incredible applets and bullets and we
need to scrape as many points off of him
as possible so that game just began all
games began actually
and it is new for me like doing this
sort of layout with chess comm so let me
see if I switch to Katarina game cool so
it should just stay like that sweet okay
so hopefully this will be instructive
for the viewers I don't know how many
people are actually watching right now
but if you want to say hi in the chat
feel free I'll try and make this as
interactive as possible and hopefully it
will be educational too watching
top-level games apart from just playing
so we have a London in shock Nagle vs.
Lindley London very trendy opening these
days one of my favorite openings I
wouldn't be surprised to see multiple
London's in this in this match from both
sides which I'm kind of excited about
limb is choosing a very solid setup with
Bishop e7 have a Queen's Indian type
type set up let's go to the Ox track
Chandra against amaz my new scheme here
we have some Spanish with d6 and ox shot
is already thinking wow and tell me this
was used like no time that's weird to
start thinking in this position as d6
isn't isn't like that rare but that's
good I know oxide is like notorious for
taking a long time even in rapid chess
so we'll see how that goes
ostrich I ran against Andrew tang if I'm
not mistaken Andrew played this opening
last year against Josh colas or
something similar Queens gambit declined
with Bishop e7 and Josh was prepared for
like 18 moves and then it fizzled out to
a draw so I'm curious seems like maybe
both players are out of prep Andrew is
beginning to think Ashwin has already
used two minutes so I'll keep an eye on
that we have the first commenter SM
checkmate
thanks for the wishes I think we are the
favorites
in this match but Minnesota has been
surprising everyone this season like
they've been the underdogs and almost
every match I want to say and they've
come out on top actually they have not
lost a head-to-head matchup there only
embossed points of the season were in
the Super Saturday so they are a
dangerous team and they're very solid
team from board one to board for their
board four is still about 2400 so let's
take a look at the Caterina game against
Mauricio Flores Wow what is this opening
Bishop f4 oh she played the London okay
oh and she's white efore so it kind of
transposes into a interesting perk
he plays c5 then e 5 Wow going for the
kill I just want to like sit and admire
these pawns they might be overextended
but right now they look nice d6 9 f3
Bishop g4 take take so it kind of
transposed into samba know any structure
maybe white should be slightly better
but it's going to be a fight like very
dynamic position so just getting
underway hello priyadarshan thanks for
the message let me know if the audio and
video is working there's any
improvements I can make but hopefully
it's ok first time streaming protests
League always lessons to be learned
so the ok black did the very typical
Bishop take f3 so White has a bishop
hair but black is usually happy trading
a pair of minor pieces with the space
deficits I would still prefer White's
like a six can be met with a five and
this is what we want from Catarina we
just want her to be solid manage her
time and it's completely okay for her to
to draw games
ideally play for two results either draw
or win but hopefully she won't
too many risks or go too crazy so let's
let's keep popping around let's go back
to the limb game a few more developments
London I approve okay so there's some
some comments in the chest icons yet I
don't know why although mod is blocking
one of these message but all allow it
real quick about this position honestly
I would prefer white just with the space
advantage usually positions like this
black wants to play 94 but White has
efore covered Queen f3 is a useful move
so I'm curious how Lim will will handle
this because I mean he should be the
favorite to win this game even with
black but he seems to be a little bit
worse so he takes honey 5 that's logical
the thing about Lim is like the position
might be equal but he'll just keep
grinding and keep grinding try and build
up some small advantages and he's very
good at like making a game last and then
creating winning chances later on so we
do have a comment from SM checkmates oh
we met at the high school tournaments
and I mentioned something about
analyzing viewer games uh oops those
messages were out of order okay I think
I understand the question if you want to
send me a game it's probably best to do
so I mean there's many ways to contact
me online you can send me a message on
Twitter on Facebook if you just go to I
am rosin calm which I have linked from
my twitch channel there's a contact form
so you can contact me through there you
can send me a message through chess calm
me chess there's tons of places I think
I was referring to yeah so about
analyzing viewer games I was referring
to the lecture that the st. Louis chess
club does and I only work at the st.
Louis chess club a few weeks out of the
year doing the residency position
so I'll be there in August I think so if
you if you want to send me games I'll
try and keep them in mind for August but
but yeah for now I don't really do any
like viewers lectures on a consistent
basis
more these these streams so anyway back
to the games this is gonna be a long
fight ox shots game I like the time
situation like white has a
decent-looking Center but just in terms
of time Tomas is doing a nice job at
managing his time and it's somewhat
dynamic like blacks completed with
development white still has to develop
the queenside so I if I had to bet money
I would pick black based on time based
on rating Queen B 3 maybe black can play
C 5 is very typical Spanish sort of a
pawn break for black maybe also just
drop back to c6 or play a 5 grand master
knows best but then a 3 ah there's some
tricks here let's imagine a three-night
c6 queen take b 7r f p8 would trap the
queen so why can't white probably can't
get too greedy and win the b7 pawn and
oxide of course is gonna think for a bit
longer
let's hop to another game and rooting
against Austrian I don't know what to
make of this position like White's a
little bit awkward like this Knights
blocking the bishop
you know you can't really play Knight g3
I'm not worried about Bishop take g3
maybe 9.4 it's possible this Bishop
can't really be hit and ina for may be
planning Bishop d3 it's usually unusual
for black to have played g6 and Bishop
f5 and there are cases where this Bishop
and might be awkward yeah I think I
would slightly prefer White's but of
course it's gonna be a fight all these
games are gonna be fights how things
really transformed here how did things
transform so quickly I do see we have a
question from TRX FTW which we'll get to
but I just want to look at this so the
Bishop's got traded which maybe favors
White's given that like the Benoni
Bishop is usually a very powerful Bishop
if it stays on the board and f5 really
cuz East g6 is very typical weakness
95-97
okay 96 anyway Wow I don't know if
Catarina's like playing strongly or just
going crazy the idea here is that if I
take e6 pawn to g6 Queens eighty Sixers
Bishop to e5 and also white might be
okay stacking upon in some lines just to
open the D file so wait what happened 95
97 so 96 rook f7 okay rook e1 and then
b3 b3 slow positional move I mean if
if you're white here you can't really
complain about your pieces like
everything seems pretty optimized like
the rooks perfectly placed in 96 the
bishop is good as possible Queen on at 4
and usually when your pieces are in good
squares good things are supposed to
happen
but there's so much tension in the
position so much tension with this 996
it hurts to even try and calculate here
King f1 I guess King f1 makes sense
defending the rook so if the e-file ever
opens up there will be less tactics also
night takeoff 3 doesn't come with check
and black has some stuff to think about
here I do like the fact that Katarina's
playing quickly up to minutes on the
clock is uh it's not a bad advantage and
rapid the line I would calculate here is
an I take out three Queen take out three
and I take you six pawn to g6 rook take
you six but then I mean it's black
winning a pawn as Queen d5 and maybe
even some potential for Queen take b7
and then to wait did I make that move or
she made that move or he made that move
oh I made that okay yeah we're gonna
keep an eye on this game in the meantime
let me get to TRX FTW any advice on how
to study opening theory I'm twenty
thirty seven feet a at the moment but I
don't really know how to improve my
opening knowledge and I think just
memorizing lines is bad yeah that's a
really good question I would say because
memorizing will only get you to a
certain point and the problem especially
with younger players because I work with
all young students and sometimes when
they study openings I'll just memorize
moves and then when they're putting
deviates they just have no understanding
so if you are gonna memorize a line it's
okay but you have to make an effort to
understand every move and that's I mean
it takes self-discipline like if you're
going through like some book
recommendation or using an engine to
build like an opening repertory
especially when using an engine you do
have to use your brain actively when
when looking at moves and you can't just
like passively look at a move and like
say okay I'll play that you have to you
have to understand the the smaller
details and it's always good when you're
studying openings to like constantly ask
yourself questions and even like look at
lines which maybe are suboptimal
because I think it just gives you a
better understanding of the position but
maybe some more practical advice
especially when it comes to opening
theory or studying openings in general
is find players find like strong players
who play your openings consistently like
if you play the London opening then
follow calm ski follow Carlson follow
and Wesley's been playing a lot you want
to just follow players who play your
openings if you play the dragon you can
even go old school like Kudrin but I
think it helps like too for every
opening that you have find at least one
Grand Master who plays it consistently
and that's something that's pretty easy
to do with like chess Pacey's days or
even a lot of these online resources
like chess Gamescom you type in the name
of the opening then you get the the
consistent players so I mean there's a
lot of tools to just study openings and
it's just about it's just about
discipline like putting in the time the
other thing I'll say that with every
game you play you should be able to add
to your opening repertory so every game
you play at some point your opponent
will deviate from your preparation if
you're consistently playing your
preparation so that's that's more advice
that like even online lits if you're if
you're playing like training blitz games
make an effort to at least look at the
openings after everything
uh hoop Andy finally caught one of my
streams I don't think I've seen that
name before
so welcome thanks for watching this is a
very different stream stream than normal
because usually I play I I give sigh
moles I do tactics but this is pure
commentary Wow so black played b6 and
Katarina played rookie 3 b6 was actually
a useful move because now in many lines
b7 won't be hanging rookie 3 she wants
to can't draw arrows she wants to double
up on the e-file
and make it so black should be scared of
taking on e6
let's hop around I do see that there are
still questions but well um we'll try
and look at some of these games first
what is going on how did that Bishop
what the bishop went from h6 to g7 to f8
and then it just got traded hmm was that
intended what happened here so 9a for f3
I have a feeling Osman maybe miss Knight
h7 very strong move because the bishop
couldn't retreat due to g5 and then yeah
he was forced to trade off the bishop
and it may not seem like a huge issue
but the bishop error is usually pretty
valuable especially at higher levels I'm
not crazy about this position for for
the white side black with the bishop
here queenside castling I like queenside
castling is a good move you might want
to at some point play e4 and challenge
this Bishop on f5 okay it's still gonna
be a fight I just glanced at the chat
who is mr. Rosen cheering for you can
call me Eric you don't have to call me
mr. Rosen if you don't want to I am
cheering for the Webster windmills
because I'm a manager for that team I'm
a player for that team we're in first
place in our division and if we win this
match
have amazing chances at making the
playoffs so that means I'm cheering for
Catarina and Silva in this game as
whites I'm cheering for Ashwin Jayram as
whites
I'm cheering for some Tomas boneses
black and I'm cheering for Lin lay also
is black things are heating up so
probably what I'll do I'll keep the
questions in mind in the chat but we're
gonna focus on the games for the next
like ten minutes or so but feel free to
keep the questions coming and I will
I'll make note of answering them like
between rounds so um yeah Andrews
playing well very positionally this
Bishop on a five which was awkward
before is now like very stable because
g4 can't really be played Ashwin might
want to play Bishop d3 at some point but
I do like the time situation especially
against Andrew you have to not get too
low on time uh katarina Oh your Queens
awkward g5 good move yeah I think
Katarina went a little bit too crazy in
this game
Queen h2 is so sad mm this hurts to
watch let's move on to another game
Raksha Chandra okay so we left this game
when things were pretty peaceful in the
middle game like around here so a three
was played nine a six okay b5 so White's
being your kind of aggressive 94 Bishop
to b5 it's a very tense position I mean
there's so much tension between the
pawns pressure on the e-file pressure on
the C file
this is one of the moments where I feel
good to be doing the commentary I don't
actually have to stress out about this
position too much I kind of like this f5
move though challenging the night if
white takes on passant
black is probably ready to take on e4 if
that if white doesn't take then f4 and
g5 might come
I feel like f5 is maybe an easily
overlooked move to yeah this line with
Uncas on take take take it still looks a
little unclear that's probably what's
gonna happen Lim is five minutes down on
the clock what against their board for
what I mean if Flynn gets a winning
position he'll win even if he's low on
time but this is scary
did Lim disconnect oh no the the okay he
clearly didn't disconnect because he it
shows him excellent connection very low
lag I'll make sure he's still in the
zoom zoom meeting room actually I should
make sure everyone's there Lim is there
category nazar
why don't I see Osman
okay Ashwin I'm probably overlooking him
because there's so many people let's
look at sorry it's hard to keep track of
everything I'm wearing so many hats
right now I'm a manager for the team I'm
trying to do commentary I make sure
everyone's on the same page like between
rounds with the score so we'll keep an
eye on this game I who's better what's
the material it's equal material so many
windows okay I'm gonna have the chat
open yeah I know
PD is watching PD if you want to make
sure OSH wins and zoom I did see him
earlier so he should be there somewhere
okay so box currently down upon but
these two pawns are very weak and
there's also a three-on-two majority for
black on the queenside which I don't I
need any dynamic imbalances should favor
them rookie one looks a little bit
annoying here let's say rook AE one
because I take T four runs into ei Queen
but maybe just king f7 seems pretty
controlled for black both pawns very
weak BOTS down the pawn now but he could
very easily be up upon him just a few
more moves we're gonna go to the auction
how things are really heating up uh it
looks like b3 was played yeah d3 things
got traded
x-ray vision happening do you have to be
careful as black c6 looks somewhat
natural
but I'm not in any business to try and
guess moves as katarina just losing
she's still up on time oh but she's just
losing down the exchange no comp she has
a bishop not enough though that said
well all it takes is one now slip two to
come back this game this game is very
tense
oh but White's just down the pond how
did he lose upon something happened on
the kingside f4 was weak Queen c7 good
move okay so we might be in trouble this
match or at least his first round
because Caterina's gonna lose if Ashwin
loses authority to to 0 we need limb to
win which hopefully will happen d5 was
played mighty for good move
attack the bishop very patience in
recapturing the pawns so let's let's
mark a win for Lin hopefully and let's
look at this game which is probably the
most complex out of all of them pawns
it's 5 to 6 if I'm counting correctly
but this pawn is pretty dead block has
two knights which I think are usually
better than night in Bishop oops
hard drive just fell on the floor let me
disconnect that
mites are solid d4 as potential weakness
for a long time I didn't mean to play
Quincy b5 so this is a current position
time is good for black which is good we
would love it if it stays that way
actually we have a time advantage in all
the games
Katerina's show up on time even though
she's lost
Ashwin if I shrink and like somehow hold
a draw that would be amazing but we're
gonna stay on the hawk shot game I feel
like every game with Oxshott is kind of
come down to some crazy time scramble
when he's like below a minutes in the
middle game so he's a fun player to to
watch in that regard I'm gonna take a
quick moment reorganize the windows I
have two laptops with me so I'm gonna
make sure everything's under control
with the stream I'm also going to go
ahead and mod priyadarshan so PD you
have powers now in the chat don't abuse
them cool yeah this is gonna be very
tense c6 is weak but blacks up on time I
would try and play guess some move here
wait blacks down the pawn way this is
just worse for black we could very
easily lose this first match or this
first round we need either Ashwin or
Tomas to pull through also Lim please be
winning
this is scary multiple points of
pressure but black is up upon this is
very scary I would be scared in this
position as black because that five is a
target beast b5 as a target there's so
much pressure on the D any files but
does white have a threat black just play
and move like g6 Lim Lim is usually very
good at not kidding in time trouble but
I don't know what's going on here when
does White's threat
I felt f4 okay
take take uh-oh so things are trading oh
that's what he was calculating okay that
happened quickly uh
Tomas blundered Oh No ro takes c6 wait
what
Queen take b5 coming
Oh Queen take b5 attacks rook on you too
but I don't know what's going on
can black defend everything somehow he
just lost another pawn
wait he's still down only one pawn wait
slow-motion replay Oh material was equal
he lost the pawn now black is
temporarily up the exchange but about to
lose her rook that's not good there's no
tricks that's not good
I don't see any tricks that's bad if
Tomas loses Katherine already lost which
was expected ashwin under pressure I do
apologize for things blocking the board
I have so many friends on chess calm and
whenever they go online or offline it
pops up or maybe just online but ok
we'll try and stay focused with these
games uh this is looking almost like
checkmates the queen bee one even I take
you to and then queen bee ones just over
right uh us win
why is Andrew thinking here yeah queen
bee one
okay so Ashwin loses Wow this is gonna
be a fight
aspirin hoping for some dirty stalemate
check despite having three pawns
inspired by me okay let's look at the
remaining remaining two games we're
already down to zero
it feels bad but I will update the
scoreboard let's say let's steer with
two okay I don't have like a team of
people behind the scenes so trying to do
all of this on my own
let's replace that so hopefully the
scoreboard is now updated zero to
Oxshott one I have to update the
scoreboard again
Lim please win it's currently three zero
black is better here but he has 16
seconds this is scary
let me give my team some moral support
on Facebook no problem stay strong and
keep fighting okay
I mean Lim is like an N game guru he
should not lose this or draw this he
should win this hopefully to pass pawns
he's up to pawns he's gonna win this
just don't know it and don't lose
connection
see three can move yeah those pawns are
nasty sometimes when they're separated
though it is harder to push them but I'm
pretty sure Lim knows what he's doing
sheltered the king all he needs to do is
queen one pollen that c-pawn looks like
it's headed for her victory
Queen it now
nice job okay the game is in the bag so
it's gonna be three one I'll update the
scoreboard again one two three okay we
need to fight take it one game at a time
so Lynn one zero zero okay and we're
gonna save that so there will be a small
break between games we have five minutes
I believe so okay
PT's handling our chat that's good
okay uh halftime show
not even a halftime show just a small
break I'll go back I'll read the chat
I'll try and answer any questions if I
don't answer the question that you want
answered feel free to just repeat
yourself I don't mind
just keep it chest related and
appropriate so SM checkmate had some
follow-up questions it looks like ot RF
oh okay anyone you'd recommend to study
for English or Yugoslavia tak hmm
Fisher right didn't Fisher play like
English attack Yugoslavia tak trying to
think who else I mean any like modern
player who plays a four-car yakun
Fabiano I think they're pretty well
known for playing e4 against and and
open Sicilians against most most
variations also moto love who I played
actually played him about six months ago
and I remember is so hard to prepare for
him because he was playing all these
main line open Sicilians as whites and
of course I got crushed
so yeah use use a tool like chess base
or chess Gamescom to to find players I
would go into more detail of how to do
that but we're gonna try and keep it uh
I'm gonna try and answer as many
questions here they miss anything else
yeah they yada you'll be 1600 in no time
some recommendation okay I'll check that
out later
Lee chess okay okay
what is a dog's rating mmm unrated but
he's good at other things like sleeping
and barking okay we are going to reset
can I even reset this we can actually go
back like look at some of the key key
moments in these games I'm curious like
how Lin got the decisive advantage like
it did transpose into this like crazy
series of exchanges King us6 so critical
I guess there's also rook d6 Makino six
is nice holds on to the extra pawn
defends everything active king king
power I like it and then he won both
pawns yeah that's one thing I'll
recommend regarding end games if you
want to improve your endgame technique
or just study end games take a look at
wins games or as many people call him
laQuan Liam and just find a game that's
over 50 moves and like just watch how he
plays because he's just so efficient
with his pieces he's also very
resourceful
I've played them twice in tournament
chess and both games he just completely
outplayed me in two different sort of
end games one on get Li drawn and he
just ground me down the other end game I
was worse and he had like flawless
technique so anyway uh uh improved
strategy okay improved strategy I think
he's a new viewer welcome thanks for
watching games start in one minute tell
my team
and they should load up automatically at
some point I'm gonna have to refill my
tea but for now I'm okay a little bit
left but yeah let me know for whoever is
watching let me know where you're from
curious if there's viewers outside the
US or if you are in the u.s. let me know
what state you're in I'm just curious
what kind of reach we have and then if
you have any questions anything just
really that anything you want to know
feel free I'll try and answer most or
all of them if I don't answer all of
them you can send me a message on many
different platforms
ooh Alberta Canada Illinois I'm from
Illinois Sweden not bad
TRX FTW has another question can you
explain why
can you explain when you need to play an
end game with correct technique and when
with calculation oh that's a difficult
question
Soraa question that makes me think like
what is he even asking correct I mean
correct technique is when like you're
you have a clear advantage and you have
to convert right and technique is
usually about the clearest and cleanest
way of converting an advantage so the
two can kind of overlap like they're not
exclusive from each other calculation is
simply when you when it's somewhat
forcing when there's either like a pawn
race or some combination or even when
there's not so many pieces on the board
and you have to basically solve the
position to figure out what's going on
it would be probably more helpful to
look at some examples regarding
technique and calculation but but both
of them are important for friend games
so but anyway let's let's take a quick
look at the games
Wow so another London
what is this line you played Knight c3
so early clear ideas of Knight b5 like
there's a funny trap if black plays
Knight c6 Knight b5 is like almost
winning or is winning so that's why
Katerina played a6 and then Andrew took
on c5 and then knight c6 I like knight
c6 just simply preparing e5 also
preventing b4 Bishop e5 is prevented
neither 3 makes sense
I would guess Katarina will play e6 and
try and recapture the pawn yeah
interesting opening I mean I'm hoping
it's not too harmful for black but we'll
keep an eye on it improve strategy
thanks for the the comments I love your
lectures they are the best ooh thank you
me screenshot that I'm trying to collect
screenshots of of nice comments I like
asking hard questions okay if you ask
too many hard questions I'm gonna just
get tired so just pace yourself how do
you suggest dealing with time pressure
internments oh okay this question I can
just direct you to a blog article that I
wrote maybe even you see if I can access
it through my website would be easiest
will this work no Eric Rosen time
trouble I'm just trying to find the
article Eric Rosen time management's
maybe come on okay if you google my name
and time management it's like the fourth
results I'll just share them the chats
Tomas is not on board what
shoot okay oh here's bad connection
what's going on remember offline okay I
have to take a break because we have
some issue with our team Tomas
so I could sign this is time odds I know
I'm still on stream Oh H it's kind of
awkward but not online for 35 minutes uh
okay can we call it okay oh he's back
okay that's good
that was weird what does that sound okay
so many things are happening I just have
to make sure that's not like the fire
alarm uh-huh let me minimize some stuff
I might just be right back
where's that the phone ring what does
that sound okay I'm gonna leave it on on
limbs game our top layer our biggest
hope he's playing on chats I will be
right back
okay nothing to be concerned about just
a phone ringing but I think the phone
has like a different ring tone shoot I
just see all over the place
Wow okay well that's the nature of
twitch doing these raw live streams it's
not Lisa didn't spill on the laptop okay
back to the games
let me reorganize my windows uh yeah it
wasn't a fire alarm thank you for the
concern but okay let's do a quick like
walk through of all the games just to
got first impressions I like limbs
position but like why is he using so
much time he spent over a minute on move
9 I mean this should be opening theory I
would think but maybe Oksana is playing
weirdly c6 before d5 I mean I like like
White's position it should be okay
Katarina blundered no please tell me
that oh no wait what where's the blunder
he 694 94 okay okay oh she forgot that
what did she forget that
I mean she's down a pawn she's been down
upon since d takes d5
oh okay
period arson is just not seeing things
that's good that's what I was hoping for
but this is this is a crazy position a
lot of things are attacked this nice
hanging this night's hanging the Kings
no longer ever gonna castle there's so
much pressure on d5 and black is winning
back the pawn if she wants to take on c6
she also has ideas not right away but
it's maybe at some point they should
take out 392 check also ideas rook d7 I
don't mind her position I might even
prefer black here slightly worse pawn
structured but black has more piece
activity about to control the D file
safer King and she has a slight time
advantage maybe Z Fox disagrees but does
e Fox like Andrew in the position or
just like Andrew as a person because
those are two very different things
okay we're gonna move on let's look at
Tomas game giving his opponent time odds
but very reasonable position some sort
of symmetrical Greenfeld
of it started out very symmetrically and
then d4 d6 so more of a kind of King's
Indian and then like the moment black
plays g5 it's more resembling a
Greenfeld so
I may be a slight pole for whites but he
does have to watch his time action on
Nagel a very efficient player when it
comes to time management and I actually
played Sean Nagle last year and he was
smashing me but then he Mouse slipped
and like hung all his pieces and somehow
I won so but when he doesn't Mouse if
he's a really good player let's look at
the only game we haven't looked at yet
which is Mauricio Flores against Ashwin
a Catalan Bishop before check Bishop d6
I think the idea of Bishop d6 is to go
into some of these like stonewalled
position it's like eventually the
vengeful Knight e4 followed by f5 but
that didn't happen of course they may
reach some other position f5 ambitious
b6 this interesting a5 is usually
weakening but here
I mean it's giving blacks some nice
central control C 6 isn't really a big
weakness the bishop on e4 is very strong
some white squares weakened in White's
position but on the other hand white is
pretty stable like things are you still
under control and it's a question of
whether black can can continue to
improve and make progress so we're gonna
move on let's leave a game open what's
the most interesting game probably this
game she took with pawn and then h3 so
leave that open I'll glance at the chat
uh fire alarm raid from Braden am I
being raided what's going on I still
don't fully understand the concept of a
raid but thank you I guess
uh did you get a GM norm if that
question was for me I have no GN norms
and
fortunately I was close twice I was
actually the the one person who killed
my chances at a GM norm was none other
than Ashwin jayaram who's playing this
game is black I needed to beat him in
the last round of Chicago open and I
think was 2015 and I was beating him I
was up a full rook and then I just gave
him a rip back when I could have just
kept the rook and be winning and that
was really disappointing because if I
won that game I would have got a GM norm
I would have tied for first place at
Chicago open with Jeffrey Zhang a head
of like all these strong GM's including
cops key I also would have won like
seventy five hundred dollars so that was
probably the most disappointing drama
that I've ever had all thanks to a
Schwinn but that's life what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger sometimes I
don't know if I'm missing any other
really important comments right now
we're gonna keep an eye on the games
Ashwin being very ambitious with nicey -
I mean I don't know what his plans after
rook c1 but he is having some threaded
Bishop d3 but the problem is rook c1
Bishop d3 rook takes you to Black's not
winning material oh maybe he just wants
to take on f3 like take on that three
and take on d4 he gives up whoa that's
actually really complicated he's giving
up some exchange but he has 92 in the
end okay let's calculate so oh it's hot
bishop take out three Queen take a three
there's also bishop take a three button
I take T four so let's start with Queen
take a three and I take T 4 Queen take a
eight Queen take a bishop take a ninety
to check King let's say G - I take c1
I think that's okay for black winning
upon and if Bishop take a three and I
take T for Bishop taking AIDS Queen take
a eights black SoundExchange but there's
comp and there's I there's threats of
Knight f3
and if f3 there's Bishop c5 whoa it's
happening they're playing so fast so
Queen take a a bishop take aids not okay
ninety-two first fine
or will he take the rook first guess
there's a few options he takes the Queen
take the rook black maybe is just up
upon and Ashwin is maybe just a beast so
it's looking good
cuz if I can't get trapped
he's a he even has threats of night take
a two at this Bishop moves
I like it nice calculation surprised he
played it so quickly but he probably
just calculated like he spent all his
time like these three minutes you spent
on Knight see two you probably just saw
that whole line Bishop c6 played white
might have some comp with the bishop
here but hopefully it's not too much
mmm I take a two runs into Rock a one so
probably 93 okay things are kind of
setting down wherever the knight moves
we're gonna keep going
katarina a huge time advantage ten
minutes to five minutes she played rook
d7 Andrew spent almost four minutes on
Queen c2 that's a good sign if n if
you're making Andrew think then he
probably is a bit uncomfortable but it's
still very complex black has some
initiative Bishop f5 candidate move
Bishop they got 392 also something to
look into
okay Braden is asking about 93 and
Bishop c5 in the Osman game 93 was
played Oh Bishop c5 for black
that's an idea the bishop c3 was played
yeah Bishop c5 White's probably has some
move like f4 so Bishop e5 like black
just wants to equalize I like Bishop e5
he's basically just forcing the trade
and b2 under pressure in many lines
there should be five as nice move okay
so Katarina doing well
Ashwin doing well - moz with the time
odds now has a reasonable position
actually maybe some positional edge
because c6 is sort of a backward pawn
the white structure is clearly better
here two pylons versus three-point
islands but it's gonna be a fight but at
least at least two Maas is connected and
I'm playing now this position how many
pawns does each side have so White's
down upon and black has a bishop here
but White has more activity but is it
enough this is shark if white can win
back up on it should be better for
whites I just like whites whites pieces
better than blacks but the question is
can he win back the pod not sure
but this is one of the reasons why I
enjoy watching especially watching Lin
play is because when I'm not sure what
to do in a position he'll play and he
shows you what to do and then then I
just kind of watch in awe like H for
like that's a nice move preparing some
maybe 95 maybe even H 5 go for some King
side attack and I think it's important
to keep in mind some tactical
possibilities like in some positions
where block wants to play c5 it runs
into Knight f6 and Bishop take B 7
winning material so tall rules routing
for Webster thanks for the support
couldn't black played Bishop take T 4
instead of Bishop g7 in this game oh and
this game yeah Bishop take T 4 it winds
up on but it opens a file and I assume
rec t1 and White has a lot of
compensation cuz c5 is met with night
oops I'm struggling here Bishop Daisy
for rook t1 c5 is met with Knight f6 and
e5 is probably met with some actually I
don't know there's a c4 of t1 a 5 maybe
92 white would win back at least upon
but it would be complicated for sure 92
c4 is attacked yeah I don't know ox I
didn't want to take the risk
because when you lose pawns you open
files it's one of uh one of the
strategies when lemons using in this
game oh I forgot to tweet but I think TV
is handling the Twitter I just got the
notification that's cool okay what game
to look at so this is a fight but I do
like limbs chances because he is when to
Maas shark position by like weights
position because c6 is still under
pressure but both sides are trying to
attack on King side so it could get
messy
but I have a feeling that like if
someday every Queens get traded then a
white should just have a nice positional
edge but I don't know very imbalanced
let's move on this game box just up up
on go Osman and the Katarina game still
up on time things have kind of settled
down so she went for this 92 immediately
Wow okay and then she took with night so
she keeps her Bishop hair and then she
castles King g2 I mean I think I would
still prefer black but Andrew is kind of
managing to untangle was that the King
side actually looks pretty well defended
for whites
white wants to focus on these weak pawns
at some point like when a Forex e ones
so there's some concerns but I mean you
got to give it to black for having more
chances like the rook can come to d8
maybe to t2
it's a fights untangle I like it you
can't spell untangle without tang and
you can't spell ashwin without wind
those are some some worthy tweets right
there for for PD uh let's look at oh she
plays f6
ooh positional she wants to play e5 and
make this bishop depressed that makes
sense she also wants to improve her
bishop potentially my only concern with
this game is it could last a lot longer
and Katarina just has to manage your
time because andrew is like 2800 in
bullet before makes sense maybe we'll
just stay with this game unless people
like if someone wants to wants me to
focus on a game just let me know
Bishop c5 Bishop c5 is an attacking move
it's also a preventive move she's
preventing Bishop e3 and she's attacking
f2 she's also attacking b2 Wow so
multi-purpose it was some nice chest f6
was - Bishop c5 is nice black might be
winning upon
and why probably means to defend f2
losing f2 it just weakens Akeno locks
so maybe Bishop g3 but like the problem
for the white bishop g3 some eventually
five or maybe queen take b2 and then
eventually five and this bishop would be
stuck for a while so Braden is saying
rook Athlon Queen take B to Bishop take
a six that's a line yeah but I have a
feeling that black is more concerned
about just piece activity rather than
pawns so it would be a trade but black
is still active Queen b3 is a reasonable
move so now if black takes on that to
the Queen's get got traded and then Y
can take on e6 this could liquidate
pretty quickly into a draw or just like
a very draw shine game or it could say
sharp like Bishop take F to Queens
eighty-six okay it's liquidating d5
probably coming
yeah g5 is important because now the
rook can access b8 and these be pawns
are just as weak as Caterina's isolated
pawns PD is saying to Moz in trouble uh
what's going on here I like the position
earlier but he just funny to what maybe
he had to take
doesn't look like white intended this
unless you somehow get encountered play
he is threatening c6 and c5 looks like a
move but blacks up upon white has to
prove himself here
rookie one rookie one almost drops a
queen but there's queen b5
wait it's blacks move okay yes
blacksmith so I'm sure he's debating
whether or not to play c5 she looks like
one of the only candidate moves unless
he wants to sack back the pond uh Anton
squared me in the chat Nagel is a lizard
secret weapon yeah but we also have a
secret weapon
Lim lei hopefully he's doing his job I
guess he's not very secret he's just a
weapon a3 making the knight commit to
some we're not just debating between 93
and 95 and maybe Knight a six but
probably not yeah we're not very good at
keeping secrets I guess so this games a
fight still uh this game d3 was played
Wow can he play rookie one does that
trap the Queen I guess it it would lose
two rooks cuz take take White's losing
two rooks mmm so rookie one first this
is scary
Queen c4 Knight c2 wait what I don't
think that's the right game oh this game
Queen c4 he could have played Queen c4
and then breathe in saying Knight see -
mmm no Queen c4 Knight see - there's 92
and black's knight is just about tracked
I don't know why Lim didn't take on c4
oh maybe Bishop a6 I can't
I'm so bad at drawing arrows but you get
the point Queen takes c4 Bishop a6
simple tactics uh okay we're gonna I
don't know which came to look at they're
all exciting any games where okay
there's time trouble in this game oxide
is below a minutes and the position is
just blowing up which should go in limbs
favor but Lynn Lynn has two minutes
doesn't seem like a lot of time but it
is more time compared to oxides
so hopefully Lim can win that Tomas
played rugby one okay well I haven't
looked at this game in a while
Ashwin fell up upon so he's playing for
a win this past pawn should win him the
game I would hope a five so positional
it's so useful just to keep pawns on on
the dark squares out of out of reach
from the bishop okay should be winning
Oxshott is also a secret weapon yeah we
didn't know he was on their team until
Monday when the pairings went up like a
shot lives in st. Louis and we were
thinking about messaging him but yes it
wasn't to be
so if Ashwin can win this oh we haven't
looked at the Katarina game whoa it's
probably a draw but don't plunder just
King f8 just draw like a draw against
Andrews a great result
is there any game where ox at isn't in
time trouble probably not and shout-out
to z nation chess one of my only
subscribers also one of my only
moderators thanks for joining
I say doc shot once you know blitz
tournament it was like a nine round
event we played in the last round and we
were playing for a first place there was
a lot of money on the line like maybe
two three hundred dollars and there was
no delay it was just five minutes no
delay and we got to some time scramble
where I flagged him with one second left
and I only managed to flag him by like
moving my rook close to the clock and
being able to move faster than him it
was dirty but it did win me a few
hundred dollars I felt kind of bad but
that's life so this should be a draw
Mike Carroll arena and just don't go
crazy Rick before fine put the pot on a
four and then just wait so if that's a
draw whoa they both Queens Wow
I mean that should win this but it's not
trivial but if he stays above a minute
this should be winning like everything's
defended he'll slowly but surely make
progress White's King is shut out just
keep calm play chess
so Tomas went from being down on time
and giving his opponent timeouts now
being up on time material is equal this
pawn on e 2 looks like a strength but it
could be a weakness but there's so much
stuff happening with their Brooks I
don't know what's going on if he can win
the e to pawn I mean there's chances to
win this and then the Lim game
everyone's in time trouble can Lim whoa
Oxshott about to flag equal material
will stay with this game
Oxshott always fun to watch h7 is coming
or queenie for maybe queenie for nice
wait did he just loose upon okay Queen
eight good pin the bishop oh don't lose
this limb g4 okay good take the pawn
opposite call your bishops are usually
Josh except when there's Queens on the
board then it comes to home to whoever's
attacking queen h7 nice but can he make
progress this might just be a draw yeah
he's just going for the draw okay so Lim
draws their secret weapon you are not so
secret weapon moving on to Maz temazepam
the e2 pong he's on his way to try and
grind down his opponent and he's up on
time that's good real quick I have to
give him the score everyone's still
playing
Oh Ashwin one okay that's good I'll
update the scoreboard once all the games
finish this is just winning right just
push the pond yes Queen h8 or queen e5
good move okay - moz one so two and a
half we okay Katarina don't don't go
crazy
whoa don't flag don't flag okay
three seconds don't flag King at four
don't flag okay oh my gosh okay just
game time game time
yes game time claim threefold it's fine
draws fine
it's it ties a match good job Katarina I
think she went crazy but she stayed
controlled Wow so Andrew like almost
played for a win took some risk yeah
that was almost winning crazy
TRX FTW are you gonna end this dream
after Round four so yeah I'm gonna end
the stream but I might come back later
tonight with some other stuff
depending on how tired I am so that was
a long match let me check the time we
started at 15 so the next game starts in
five minutes
next round starts in five minutes
stay in zoom and live chess okay let me
go ahead update the scoreboard there's a
lot to juggle here this is tough so the
court the current match score is four to
four we lost the first round 3 to 1 and
then we won the next round 3 to 1 and
the individual results limb just drew
Oxshott Tomas Tomas just won
Wow miracle worker he won
Ashwin one and then Katerina drill good
comeback let me save that troll ass
hopefully it updated save did it update
it updated awesome ok so small break the
next bit starts in four minutes let me
look at the chats I'll answer any
questions I might just use this time to
cool down so I'm not going to do
anything too intensive if you're gonna
ask questions ask asked some easy
questions Braden so Brandon was asking
what's what's the score it is updated on
the stream it's four to four
Anton squared me is he looks like a
blizzard fan just said fudge which
usually doesn't have the best
connotation TRX FTW it's 1:30 a.m. where
are you you see from Sweden or maybe
Europe I don't know okay
so Anton squared me is from Minnesota
interesting I will I will keep him I'll
allow him to keep commenting as long as
he stays civilized John played Oxshott
last week in st. Louis oh so maybe John
is a problem he stole Oxshott that's too
bad agent for Bartholomew interesting
like a secret agent or just uh public
agents do you like sloths I compete with
sloths like they're sleepy but I'm
sleepy it's a matter of who's the
sleepiest Netherlands interesting okay
Netherlands is what like eight hours
something eight or seven hours I'm gonna
be right back I lost a lot of tea from
spilling it all over the place so let me
get something easier to drink I'll be
back in like a minute
in the meantime I'll just leave a game
open which game to watch Eric Hanson why
not
okay I'll be right back
oh okay
got some good old-fashioned water not
yeah that the beer points let's stick
with water for now okay we're gonna so
many things to do I'm gonna make sure
everyone is still in live chess and pin
zoom so limb
Karina's online limbs online Tomas is
online
Ashwin where are you ash wins online
that's good looks like everyone's in the
meeting limb Ashwin - moz Katerina
awesome okay so the game should start
any moment now where the games dude
starts let's get out of the Eric Hansen
game and let's take a look at the games
um Sean Eagle playing nyah three going
into some English ready type stuff could
transpose into some cattle and uh
Oxshott Chandra playing just playing
some fianchetto also ready Wow
everyone's playing the ready everyone's
playing that of three last game oh my
gosh I've never seen so many readies in
my life
neither three every game on move 1 it's
like these are almost the same games
except this game I guess I forgot about
this game's not already
there are three readies uh this game is
oh it's the same opening that Ashwin
played sort of but with g4 h 4 g5 he
keeps pushing his pawns ok I assume that
some Theory I'm trying to remember who
played that at US Championships I want
to say it was Fabiano against Slenderman
Fabiano Lenderman 2016 let's check my my
memory ability Lenderman was yeah
Linderman was white and lost pretty
terribly and then Jeffrey gelling was
really impressed by Fabiano playing the
sign is black am i right yeah it's same
line
hey my memory is not as bad as I thought
it was let me I'm just gonna share that
game in the twitch chats because I was a
really cool game and shows how black can
win with this opening Lenderman Fabiano
2016 and chess games so feel free if you
just want to see a high-quality game how
to win with the Queens gambit declined
this is one one good line to know for
lack there you go
I assume Lim is well-prepared and if I
remember correctly this is a pretty
sharp dynamic line like both sides have
chances so anything can happen but I
like the matchup like Andrew has a lot
of experience playing like very strong
GM's and in quick time controls online I
know he's played Carlsen many times
Nakamura many times but I don't know how
many times he's played Lim so we'll see
what happens
um let's see how the ready games are
going uh Creighton wants to see some
clothes Roy's gonna have to wait
unfortunately this game somehow
transposed into what do we call this a
tirage I think this is a tirage I think
he may be tricked Catarina if she plays
the trash but it's I don't think it's a
bad opening especially for rapid like
black gets piece activity in space from
early on what is this some kind of
clothes Catalan Bach played some
Greenfeld set up but White has bishops
it could be a long grind and then Ashwin
oh this is actually I have some
experience with this line except not
this move warrior I know the line where
but white plays my a3 and then Bishop
take a three but with a six included it
looks similar usually black gives back
the pawn because black is up a pawn in
this position and then the planter Lac
is just to play knight c6 Bishop e6
usually something like ninety-seven and
f6 just solidify White has two bishops
but some slightly weak pawns on the
Queen side so it is round three match is
tied four to four still gonna be a fight
given the way the first round went I
think it's anyone's match it's gonna be
close I am checking in
I am looking in the chat so if anyone
has any games you want me to look at any
questions send them my way
TRX FTW I know where white plays Bishop
to each six and black plays nine th six
what
oh and French oh I know he's talking
about there's some resemblance to the
French like you you got a bad pawn
structure as whites but here you have
two bishops in a relatively open
position and too much ready yeah for
anyone watching if you want to be
entertains you can follow us on twitter
our twitter handle is webster windmill
we couldn't get Webster windmills
because it's beyond the character limit
for a Twitter username so Webster
windmill chess pros are losing again
ouch they're playing st. Louis right I
haven't checked the score and the other
the other matches
um yeah Archbishop's are doing well uh
well there are odds ooh that's nice so
the chest come whatever algorithm
they're giving us a 59% chance to win
this match so that's nice
but you can never trust numbers
sometimes they're deceiving znation
chess was asking if Bobby is smacking
them down Bobby is not playing for some
reason I think feathers a was playing
who else is playing a Kobe in jariabek
and Forrest Chen I think I'm right with
that but don't trust me oh I have a
Fabiana story it's a terrible story but
it happened the other day I was so proud
of it so I thought there's a social
media platform I follow Fabiano on and
he posted the picture
of like this lake and the lake was like
half ice and half water and he had a
caption it said what did it say it said
half a frozen lake and then I like I saw
the snapchat like I didn't really think
I saw the UM yeah it was a snapchat but
I saw the picture I didn't think much of
it and then I was at this like Starbucks
and I was getting coffee and I was
thinking of getting a snack and the only
snacks I'd had were like muffins and
they were like these those prepackaged
muffins and there were six of them and
then it like dinged in my uh like I had
this lightbulb moment where there were
six of them and they were muffins I took
a picture of them and sent it to him and
captioned it half a dozen cake which I
thought was a great response to half a
frozen lake but anyway uh that was a
terrible story let's move on with the
games Ashman defending his e-pawn weight
90 percent oh they could say anything
from ten percent from to ninety percent
yeah the the numbers are never accurate
the numbers only look at ratings and
they don't look at and routing which is
a big factor for the blizzard so they
may very easily overlook secret weapons
this is interesting though like this
Bishop is now happy but this Bishop is
now sad h3 might be coming at some point
also white can win a couple different
pawns like white could probably win
either phone like what's wrong with well
I guess my TIGI for walks into some pin
also night Tiki fort could run in
tonight Tiki for Bishop taking for
Bishop to g4 Queen's Agee for him and d2
hangs in that
so I don't know Queen takes c4 logical I
was about to suggest rook e8 f seven
would be be hanging maybe 95 as a move
or maybe just I'm I'm a queen e7 I have
a feeling he 4 is pretty weak though cuz
white already has for your attackers he
can play Bishop take f6 whenever he
wants the base camps just got stronger
Rea Robson is here shoutout to Ray
Robson hopefully not judging me too much
on my commentary probably not even
watching my commentary to be to be real
but Braden suggesting Bishop g6 and then
Ricky aids I look slow but maybe let's
try and find a more exciting game this
game is right for excitement
hasta sy castling open G file and it's
Ock no it's not oxide it's Andrew I can
swim our two weapons or one of them is
our as one of them is theirs but okay
this is going to be exciting
I like the fact that there's all these
weaknesses along this diagonal given
black has committed to h6 Knight f3
Knight 5 looks such a simple plan
followed by ripped g1 I mean this
position seems easier to play for whites
but Knight g4 hitting the bishop
anything f2 is three anyway I guess he
doesn't care about the bishop he just
wants an e5 square for the knight and
then once he can infiltrate be five
there's gonna be more opportunities
Knight g6 possibilities even Queen g6 or
Bishop d6 g6 such a big weakness also
Richey one coming someone offered the
draw what's who offered the draw uh
katarina didn't maybe I'm just going
crazy
I thought I heard the draw for noise but
maybe not hmm that's strange
Oh Tomas declined to draw I guess that's
a good thing if he's playing for a win
hmm so is this position yeah maybe he
didn't hear the draw offer uh what you
never know the grand scheme of things if
that's a good or bad thing it's a short
position though like black might try and
do something on the Kings side maybe
some day prepare g5 in the meantime
White has some positional ideas on the
queenside b7 is the target and white
still has the two bishops and c-file
might be opening up so stuff is
happening let's try and make predictions
based on the games so far I'm gonna
predict that Lin will win just with just
simply with all these arrows I mean the
position just looks very rich with ideas
for whites the Ox shot game carry the
slope on time which I like not the most
difficult thing to do again stock shots
but
what happens so she's holding onto her
deep on a I think best-case scenario
this is a draw but I feel like a back
shot is gonna somehow make use of his
two bishops and the fact that he's
playing against to meet deep on so we'll
give it to hawk shots but I do I do have
hope in Katarina this game the position
transformed Bishop e6 was played and
it's still shark I think I like white
though
or do i I don't know because Bishop e2
Knight e5 comes the Queen has to move
away the Knights super solid on d5 I
mean objectively it's probably equal but
maybe White's pushing for something if
you can get the pawn to a5 and then have
all this potential with a six and then
these two pawns could someday be
destabilized yeah I would rather be like
here so if Tomas can win that what's
going on here oh this was a weird before
pawn on e4 game I'm trying to count
blacks down a pawn but these pawns are
slightly better than one pawn this is a
weird position it's four on two on the
Kings side
White's probably just better and
triangles strong he's using his time
well
okay we need some some good stuff to
happen for us hop around these games
just a little bit yeah we'll stay on
this game for a little bit a look on the
other screen I'm gonna check out Twitter
to see if there's anything notable
though I'm missing have some support
from the one and only Susan Polgar keep
up the momentum John Bartholomew is
tweeting sweating the blizzards yeah
they got a big match okay
lots of smiley faces for some reason
anything else notable double bishops
whoa I like the I like the pig
that's a nice Pig if anyone watching
isn't on Twitter go on Twitter check out
the pig that's nice
okay backs for the games uh rook F 1
that looks passive yeah it's gonna be a
fight white slow playing this this 95
move is gonna have to wait Andrews done
a good job of kind of neutralizing
White's play like Knight g4 good move
then Bishop d6 good move I'm just having
things on your control
neither 400 I think Lim overlooked that
oh no he's losing a pawn
wait okay you just want a piece what's
going on
I will admit I didn't see 92 and maybe
Andrew didn't see it either maybe he
just assumed he was winning the night
the 92 uh maybe there's some cop like
Queens 84 but okay he took on d4 but you
spent 17 seconds to take okay it's
getting charkh this is what we we
watched chess for black has two pawns
for the piece I mean I would prefer
whites just because wing is white but
extra piece is an extra piece f2 might
be falling but I don't think it's a huge
deal as long as white can somehow get
initiative or at least keep things
somewhat defended rook g1 anytime build
up that pressure that's very good sign
that black is thinking here
I'm guessing he yeah he probably just
forgot about 92 but he spent almost a
minute on that for you would think you
this is a mainline he's calculating but
eight minutes for whites extra piece SM
checkmate is asking night take F to
Knight f3 9 f3
attack the Queen obstruct the rook it
might run into Queen f4 and then white
might have to go back to d2 so I don't
know maybe it would lead to some
repetition but might take f2 I mean
maybe just ripped g1 or burgage - yeah
ok let's hop around a little bit more
Ashwin has passed pawns but white has
two pieces this is actually really
interesting I mean you got a favor white
here given the 19 bishop like if Mike
can blockade the pawns
if he can't blocking the pawns that
would be that would be good for black
and sometimes this position is easier to
play for black because really all you
got to do is push pawns and it's a
question of how bite can places pieces
to stop the pods
so Sean Eagles gonna be thinking
Tomas re1 how did he win won by
resignation
what oh wow
what Queen c7 Queen c8 Queen take a five
oh that's a blunder black had to fail a
croquet back
Wow so sneaky not even sneaky it's just
a blunder well nice job Tomas that's a
crucial point given that we need all the
points that we can get I'll go ahead
I'll update the scoreboard
Tomasz beats Mauricio Flores and the
first game to finish in round three the
math score is 5 to 4 this is the first
time we're leading the match it's a
miracle
just got to keep it up a control save
JPEG enter replace ok so only three
games left and tomales gets some rest
that's nice britain's asking what's my
longest win streak over the board I
don't even know I guess you could ask
like my feed a win streak and my US
chess win streak I'm sure their
difference I have no idea maybe there is
one year I went 7 out of 7 at the high
school nationals and then if you count
my tournaments before and after that it
would probably be at least 10 games I
would hope but I don't know not
memorable enough to keep track of
this game huge time advantage this game
still a reasonable time advantage for
Katarina I like the transformation she
got her pawn to e4
so she no longer has a iqp white still
has a bishop pair but the Katarina is
good at putting her pieces on logical
squares we saw this in the other game to
make her first round game this
everything kind of makes sense
rooks in the center bishop on b7 and
knock shots thinking so that's nice so I
think we're pretty comfortable in these
these two games with Katarina and Lynne
the Austrian game is probably the
craziest woo he might be winning the 85
if you can win a 5 I'm gonna have three
connected pastors even if he loses one
pass or you would still have to
connected pastors just take on a five
and then there's work a two ideas and
this is sharp white what white wants to
win b3 as quickly as possible so some
move like 92 or Bishop d1 the problem is
that box pawns are coming down quickly I
actually don't know what's going on here
92 good move of attacking b3 and c6 I'm
guessing - when we'll have to lose one
part
this is a position to calculate which
pawn to lose does he wanna make the move
to the Fen b3 would be Brooke a three
and then push the a pawn but it looks a
little bit awkward he could go for a c5
but it might be too slow oh I forgot
that Bishop take c6 could be met with
Brooke take g4
so maybe you're okay three is a move
here and then then at least make white
think whether or not to take on c6 but
he plays c5 okay
so probably rook take b3 Braden's giving
some some long line c5 rook to e3 roots
a b3 Rick b5 and maybe c4 it's possible
[Music]
yeah these I'm games are hard sometimes
hard to judge whether or not the night
in the bishop can manage to effectively
blocking the pass pawns
if black keeps outside a pawn it's
probably a bigger advantage or at least
some some hope to to play for a win and
it's good that White's thinking here
it's quickly hop over to the lame game
because he might win very quickly still
up a piece for two pawns a huge time
advantage
Andrew less than 20 seconds
maybe about to flag okay this is just
over let's go on to the Ashwin game oh
so uh Ashwin is playing like Braden
except Ashwin played rotate be three
first and they get to this position it's
complicated
c4 is a threat if the knight moves and
85 comes Wow oh he's also threatening
rotate g4 with check it's easier to play
for black not sure if flight can somehow
get a set up like if I get some Knight
to c3 and gets a Qingyun wait what oh
maybe that wasn't a bad move rook b5 and
I take a six rook take efore rotate d5
that was a good bail out from lights
this should be a drama night and four
versus Rickon to whites gonna play for a
win though this will probably be the
longest game I would guess and rooting 2
seconds left limb has so much time just
to think that's nice well watch this end
and then then we'll probably go to the
Katarina game cuz that game has haven't
looked that at that one in a while limb
just taking his sweet time here for
minutes ok quickly Katarina what's going
on not a bad position I like her chances
if she keeps up the pace looking fine
ok we'll stay with this game
maybe we'll witness a flag flag fall
rookie 7 looked interesting the pawns
are falling Andrews used to playing with
low time but yeah he's just down a piece
pawns are equal limbs gonna win this
okay let's look at the glance of Oxford
game this is scary would much rather be
White's but if he can hold a draw uh
we'll be in very good shape and then
this game
f5 interesting this Bishop is shut out
for the time being but so is the night I
like the the pace that Katarina is
playing with like she's playing well
today despite losing the first round she
someone offer to draw yeah despite
losing the first round she drew and
routing she's playing putting up a very
good fight here
I need points she gets are just
basically bonus points given our lineup
maybe Ashwin offered the draw yeah and
greenhaven to climb the draw so Sean
Nagle playing for a win he has less time
roschmann has time to think which is
good we're not quite in table-based
territory but we might get there soon at
some point a pawn will get traded and
will be like rook into vs. or a knight
and two versus rook and King so I think
as long as Austin can this maintain his
focus and not get forts that would be
ideal
but three games still going I'm shocked
rendre low on time this five seconds
left Katarina has a minute 30 looking
fine
I think I would slightly prefer black
here I don't know if it's a huge
advantage but a White's LightSquared
Bishop is just stuck and just play
Knight g6 get the knight to a better
spots at some point light will probably
play e3 but III runs in tonight of three
so I like the fact that Catarina's
leaving her knight on on h4 but now she
has a choice to make does she play King
f7 does she play g6 I can't draw arrows
but we'll see what happens she could
also play Knight to g6 and attack this
pawn
Lim is asking for the score
all of 2-0 right we okay so Lim 1 yeah
so Lim officially beat and rooting uh it
looks like Andrew flagged Knight f3 ooh
yes Katarina one watch is flagged nice
move - three three zero a last game
if Ashwin can hold will be in very good
shape that really turned around we lost
the first round one two three then we
came back three two one and now it's
three to zero hopefully three and a half
to half this round
Akash one can draw it's looking scary
though how does this keen wind up so far
on each floor we still got to take this
seriously all the points we can get
I don't like this kingi three's probably
best try but f4 is coming
ooh can he check and then it if a five
Brook a four and he wins that pawn
wow he's threatening me than one and
he's gonna hold on to his f1 but there's
my take f7 I still don't know what's
going on whites Ofelia winning actually
I forgotten I take f7 avoids any mates
um can a king run back quickly enough so
black is threatening this move no this
is just over no throwing the check okay
it is tricky though maybe not just over
bring the king and f4 don't play King f5
don't play King f5 keying a 596 ok he
sees it but what else to do
he could play rook g1 he could play King
d5 this is losing aki-nee for but just
whites gonna Queen that said Rick f4
maybe no so sad
poor Ashwin to be fair he was probably
losing most of this game oh he's gonna
go for my I still matrix uh but it's not
gonna work
good try there is a rule in protesting
you can never resign if you have a rock
left or just a king left he's hoping for
Knight f5 still means not happening
ok so three two one I'll update the
scoreboard we're in very good shape
the current match score is now
me update the match work so we have we
already have eight points eight to five
is that true
can I do math it's eight to six right
No why can't I do math eight to five but
that adds up to thirteen
maybe it's seven to five wait one plus
three plus three seven two five okay
right three plus one plus one okay seven
two five
let me just update the individual
results so Lim one
Ashwin lost Katharina one Catarina's so
clutch pulling through for us we have
one more game or one more round four
more games we need one and a half to win
this match it's not over
anything can happen stay strong guys one
more game starts last round starts in
four minutes okay so let me save this
wait that's wrong
Katharina one and then save okay I think
it's been a while since I've looked at
the chat my windows are so disorganized
because I have I have OBS I have chess
calm I Facebook I have my photoshop
where I'm updating the scoreboard
I see Anton squared me and Braden and
tall rules so guys are still involved
what do I want to do do I miss anything
important
TRX FTW is asking something about her
Carl seems random
anton squared me is clearly a Sean Eagle
fan also pointing out that because I
must
I updated the score made around it
completely mess my brain up which is
true uh getting their energy yeah we
have renewable energy it's built into
our our team somehow so it didn't start
off great but I think the team is
energized
uh the round starts in four more minute
or if not for two more minutes the
longer this goes the tire the more tired
I get the more difficult it is to say
words or do math I see max Maxie AI hey
guys what's up yeah we're gonna wait
till next round starts I'm gonna get
some more water I'll be right back for
the last round
oh this is interesting
so there's a chat on chess comm it's in
Shawn's game ox I was saying yeah
idiotic me to flag in that position in
my mouse got stuck
yeah like oxide should not flag in this
position because it's probably just to
draw if he takes yeah it's just an easy
drop to called bishops take take so
there's been many games a season where
our opponents have flagged in either
drawn or completely winning positions
and we'll take we'll take all of those
there's no there's no regrets about
those at least for us or no feeling bad
I should say if losing is learning does
that mean learning is losing that's too
confusing znation chess z nation chess
it looks like is departing and the games
are starting so z nation chess will miss
this last round but thanks for for being
here for this stream ok last rounds
ratios time is ticking d4 in one game
d4 in another game efore in this game
ooh ooh
modern ok we'll see something oh and
this slide so I think there's been a lot
of London's this match like a lot of
London's law there readies because
Andrew played
Elspeth London I think cavalry now
played the London one game Sean Nagel
played the London very popular opening
this line is trendy I know that he takes
e5 and it's a bit tricky but didn't
didn't Katerina play this line as black
against Andrew or something similar
Oh Andrew played Knight c3 okay so it's
a bit different so all we need is one
win and one draw right to clinch the
match the score is 7 to 5 we need one
win to draw the match
let's hop around if anyone wants to say
with a game let me know Katerina
whoa he's playing the hippo what it's
got a while since I've seen a hippo did
he intend to play the hippo I guess
after Bishop c4 e6 is somewhat justified
wow it's a hippo I she saw a hippo not
too long ago in December I was on some
safari in Indonesia I'm actually I'm
curious I'm gonna open up lightroom real
quick and i'm gonna try and tweet
I don't usually tweets during stream but
I'm gonna try and find the picture of
the hippo that I took and then I'll
screenshot this position and it'll be
something tweet-worthy okay
in the meantime should we stay on this
game what to do
Oh Anton can do it is Anton gonna beat
me to it
just like Photoshop a hippo like on the
board okay we'll do it anyway
where's my hippo Safari that looks
promising
it's elephants some kind of camel thing
I know there is a hippo zebra there was
only like one or two pictures oh here's
a hippo okay I got the hippo it's
already edited so what I need to do is
export that photo and then take a
screenshot computer so slow with
Photoshop Lightroom OBS chess comm I
don't know if the stream is picking up
the fan but like my computer is so hot
right now which is actually nice because
it's really cold outside
in Chicago so bring some warmth to the
to the room let's export that we'll call
it just leave it as be okay
[Music]
what should i tweets uh Sean Nagel is
playing the hippo when is the last time
you seen a hippo okay I guess I'm
tweeting for it from the Webster
windmill account which is okay so
there's a hippo and there's where's the
other hippo do I not screenshot
okay so I need to screen capture this I
apologize for the lack of chess
commentary but this is really important
Sean Nagle okay so now I have the
screenshot the chess board and the
actual hippo beautiful protests hashtag
I guess I have to tag everyone to
Webster windows protests League Sean
Nagle maybe an eagle chess chess calm I
think that's enough oh Minnesota
Blizzard okay
tweet okay so anyone who's still
watching if you want to see a picture of
an actual hippo and not just the stupid
hippo defense go to our Twitter
twitter.com slash Webster windmill know
s and you'll see the hippo in both forms
but for now let's see what happened in
this game he played g5 which is I think
a typical hippo idea at the point of the
hippo you just like waits and then you
try and bites when your opponent least
expects it so he went for g5 and then g4
and then h5 he's going crazy
but he wants to play h4 and maybe Bishop
h6 f4 looks very reasonable if black
takes on passant that file opens in fact
doesn't take on pissant white just has a
huge mass in the center and now there's
a free square for the bishop on f2 so I
think it's okay I think I prefer whites
but it is Shaun Nagel so you can never
know oh I forgot to tag Anton's squared
me I apologize I guess you could retweet
it can you retweet it and tag yourself I
don't know let me quit out of Lightroom
because it's just killing my computer
I'm seeing the spinning wheel of death
which is not good uh what
I don't want your tips okay quits skip
oops didn't want to do that okay so
everything's still working yeah things
look ok so all four games still going
the match is in our favor 7 to 5 Shaun
Nagle just played h4 which looks like
it's forcing Bishop F to these pawns are
scary
what does Katarina thinking about she
considering at five
maybe she's considering at five Wow f5
take the bishop take the knight mmm but
then rook take h2 is really scary
because I'm black is threatening rook h1
Queen h4 with mates but light gets the
first check on f7 and then King f8 I
think it's too risky for white oh but
she takes him g3 in the end I don't know
what's going on I'm too old for this
f2 is solid but it's also scary like
Bach has pressure f4 needs to be
defended my d3 makes a lot of sense
maybe it's scary for both sides chess is
just a scary game looks like black
monster Castle queenside put the other
work on g8 and go for some eventual g3
it's gonna be a fights let's go on to
some other game Ashwin Ashwin being
solid I like it mmm
doing stuff NIMS Oh Rubinstein played f3
against the recommendation of n Feingold
but I think it's smoking position he's
debating whether to take with Knights
and leave the high Q pond5 or take the
pawn and just be symmetrical
Mauricio Flores again slim what's
happening here
so it was sung-hoon fouled and the Lim
was being interesting things got traded
96 was played 9 8 5 allowing Queen take
a 8 and that's what happens so a queen
for two rooks Lim wins upon on b7 so
it's actually a queen and two pawns for
two rooks but white does have the bishop
error White has his pawn on c5 very
imbalanced usually there's a rule for
this these positions in terms of telling
who's better that if Lim is playing one
side he's usually better so I think I
would stick with that rule and prefer
black but you never know there's a
square on c4 for the night
the problem is like if Knight c4 there's
some some eventual like c6 Bishop e7 but
I don't know sometimes these positions
of the question is whether or not the
pawn is strong or weak and in this case
there's a debate so Lin might take his
time here it looks like a pretty
critical moment
Catharina whoa okay Catherina just won
the game of Connect four and that's a
tweets okay tweeting a little too much
here but anytime you see like four pawns
in a row you have to tweet about it
[Music]
Karolina wins the game of Connect or
Connect four is a really fun game
actually so much strategy and
prophylaxis and calculation protests
okay
tag everyone Church St Minnesota okay
okay um this is so visually appealing
just look at those pawns I mean black is
trying to attack the pawns but
everything's defended no friction is in
the chat hello no friction thanks for
joining
just in time for the finale of the match
Bishop II won that's awkward looking but
she is unleashing her rook
she's also making it this is actually a
really important concept when it comes
to a pawn breaks where if black never
plays g3 the files don't have to open
because white can play g3 so the bishop
no longer being on f2 actually keeps
light a bit safer so despite the awkward
square it's actually it does have some
strategic value
let's move Bishop eat one and she's
putting the ball in black's court like
what to do for black there's not too
much space to work with and he doesn't
necessarily want to commit the king like
if he castles Queen side there is
potential for a massive attack for
whites so a cavalry not performing very
well today I think she's a she was a
very solid pick for board for no
friction' didn't know that I do
commentary this is actually one of my
first times ever doing commentary for
any type of match I think I did it a
couple of times last year also for
protesting but first time this year
hopefully it's going okay it is tough
being one person but I think as long as
I don't set the place on fire or spill
everything over my laptop it should be
okay
g3 was played anyway so h3 looks like a
no brainer unless she wants to try and
win upon I think the idea of g3 is to
meet h3 with met h5 and continue to
build up pressure against this at four
pong
even though f4 is defended she took wait
what
oh she took really hmm yeah I was gonna
say even though f4 it's defended three
times there's still a lot of potential
for black to attack it like my h5 and
also e5 the pawn is pinned to the Queen
so she won upon the problem with winning
upon is it opens up files for black now
black has the open H file and the half
of the G file but a pawns upon no pun
intended castling queenside okay this is
gonna be a fun game cuz white has some
breakthrough like c5 or she's just going
for defense because she's up upon oh
maybe she's going for b4 connect six get
bonus points for that this is exciting I
could just spend all the time on this
game and not watch like any of the other
games uh let's just quickly look at
other games and then we'll come back to
this game
Tomas against Andrew tang mu also pretty
crazy equal material past C pawn races
past beep on 93 looks attractive I think
things are under control for black but
who knows c6 was played this is kind of
scary but I take c6 free pawn whoa
Knight takes c6 rook c1 so tricky
because I'm black with windaq material
after Bishop takes he won Rick take C 1
so queen c8 that's such a devious quiet
move cuz the bishop is stuck a black
just wants to take the bishop and like
the only move to save the bishop is
Bishop e7 but then they take b7 and
black ones another pond or black would
win the C pawn so then it would be queen
and two pawns for the two rooks
probably some edge for black let's check
out on Ashwin so he took with Niland d4
he's playing against iqp probably the
most positional game I love all these
games it's gonna be a long fight but he
does have the time advantage Braden is
asking about Bishop d6
probably in the limb game there should
be six in this position I mean there
should be six Knight takes c6 probably
covering d8 and then cook c1 queen take
eighth so yeah it should be okay I guess
black does have two threats like Queen
decades and they take c6 here so that's
nice and the time advantage for limb
going back to the Katarina game 'if I've
explosive also unleashing the bishop
which I don't know looks risky oh one
thing I forgot though about this Bishop
d1 move is that she's covering h5 so the
knight is somewhat restricted this
Bishop is actually really well placed on
d1 because if this Knight has to retreat
that's like one less attacker for black
so he takes take back with pawn good and
she also might be able to just
neutralize the b7 Bishop by putting her
Bishop on a3 and never forget White's up
a pawn so if it ever simplifies white
sofa pond
there's about three I like the the speed
she's treating this very well still
shark like he you can never
underestimate two rooks on on open files
but white is still dictating play r.i.p
wall she ruined it yeah I guess she was
about to build like a big beautiful wall
that black would definitely pay for
but that just didn't pan out but okay
sometimes it's okay to be positional I
gotta pick your battles yeah we could
stick with this game the time situation
in every game I think favors us Ashwin
has seven minutes to Ock shots like four
and a half minutes limb same situation
seven five minutes to four nine minutes
Katarina has seven minutes of five
minutes Tomas has seven minutes to about
five minutes so we have like a two to
three minute time advantage in every
game which is sometimes like what I
realize time can be the dictating factor
in like who's better in a match right
even in the game 9h for aggressive g2z
targets so yeah I don't know I was
liking this for whites but black has
initiative now and light f5 is coming
which is very strong outpost Square this
is scary actually I'm glad that I don't
have to deal with this but I'm a little
bit nervous for Katarina like Shaq can
she like make sure everything's covered
his nine of five comes users Queenie
four to check but it's scary I guess she
has to figure out whether to defend or
attack and clearly she's going for the
attack
neither five is met with Queenie four
check or Queen f3 check and this is
gonna be incredibly sharp c5 I like it
now there is potential for Queens to get
traded like Knight takes e5 Knight takes
e5 Queen takes e5
I don't know what's going on there
if Queens come off the board light
should be okay
I would think but this Bishop bishops
not doing much
so maybe the plan for light is to drop
the bishop back to F to like play Queen
e4 and then Bishop f2 and then hope that
there's no immediate mate for black so
the match is gonna end in like 10
minutes
well that's the thing about rapid chess
these games go by quick let's do another
quick hop over look at the Tomas game
which was a little bit crazy still is
crazy
Queen d4 check just crushing no bishops
hanging so f4 going all out I don't know
it's getting tactical black scheme does
not want to be on e7 this might be the
worst position out of all of them let's
look at the florists game limbs should
be winning this I would hope limas got
the windows rights
pony pawns his three pawns in a queen
Pasi pong potential for a spawn McQueen
side ie 5 OE 5 nice move at for coming
next
ok um
so if we if we win this game we
guarantee a draw
uh the Ashwin game all Ashwin needs to
do is draw and we should win the match
other two games are kind of toss ups
given how complicated they are but this
this looks very reasonable thank you
whites probably just slightly better but
the game could go on for a lot longer
and the heat keep hopping around here I
do see a question wait if this should
take F to rotate g2 what cane is that is
that the what game is that this is f2
Rick take G - oh and this in this game I
guess
the bishop f2 so bishop f2 rotates you
to queen takes you to Ritchie ah I see
maybe
oh she played Bishop take her bishop to
F to rook take G to wasn't played maybe
because black would be giving away two
rooks um maybe is enough for white to
hold on
iliyan is Nick in the chat I think Ilya
receives the award for strongest player
ever to watch my stream so he will be
gifted with with the mod title this is
exciting
we're ahead in the match we just need a
point and a half more hoping people
don't screw up let's get to real-time at
this game
yeah if Ilya could just tell us what's
going on here that would be nice because
I have no idea it's gonna come down to
whoever checkmates first but White House
initiative by White's threatening this
green take pawn
white also has Knights which I sometimes
tricky og8 wasn't protected ah yeah
sometimes you just assume she is
protected Illya likes whites that's good
yeah Katarina playing very well today
like she's managing her time well I know
she's been busy
like she's pursuing a PhD which I don't
think gives you too much time for chess
but maybe she's just fresh she has had a
break from chess so I'm coming back with
some energy ray believes white wins
Kayla believes Katerina will lose I
believe we will win this game wow so
many beliefs but what's the truth okay
we're gonna go forward here uh I really
want to stay on this game Brook take f3
oh there is a real kind of three okay
okay things are complicated is Lim
winning yet
Oh Lim one good timing okay so Lim 1
it's 8 to 5 we need 1/2 point out of
these 3 games we're gonna go forward
here uh and and someone yeah moderators
you might have to ban people who are
spamming but anyway I took care of that
rosin can we do one exercise
end game exercise after this round uh I
I mean I would stick around the problem
is I have a
a lesson like a like private lesson
starting at 8 in 18 minutes so I have to
I'll be busy from 8:00 tonight I'll
probably be back 11 p.m. so I'll be back
like 3 hours after this mansions so if
you want to stick around I am doing some
what daily streams too so if you miss
whatever you can go to my website I am
rosen.com
and then click on schedule and you'll
see my stream schedule there
katarina will win 100% Katrina will win
who's Katrina Caterina 68 ooh
two nights up to pons nice you can never
like take anything for granted though
all she needs is a draw Oh Caleb wants
pics to be edited you know what okay let
me send a private message right now to
Facebook
I'll only send it to Caleb because I did
edit a pic uh probably not the time to
do so given games are still going on
Caleb I completely forgot like I made
the photo and then I forgot um but Chavo
- Caleb giving support from from the
Webster crew Caleb oh no I didn't save
it as a right format okay never mind
Caleb's gonna have to wait we're gonna
focus on these games so a three game
still going
Oxshott Chandra about to flag nothing to
new Ashwin being solid I like it there
is still 10 minutes yeah there's 10
minutes for me to eat and like recover
from talking so much night 8g six stuff
is happening
that looks beautiful this should take
III I don't know what's going on things
are being captured left and right
Queen e8 not capturing the night's
Ashwin shouldn't go too crazy but I
think we have this match in the bag yeah
Catherina doing well still uh Tomas
haven't looked at in a while
this position is blowing up I don't know
what's going on things are just
everywhere I don't know which game to
look at we'll stay on this game because
it's so crazy
Tomas just got fourth there's Queen a7
check good move but the rooks still
attacked and the kings in the center 9f2
is probably met with Brooke take F to
Queen take out to Knight eighty-eights
so he plays that this night is so good
on d3 though it's controlling a lot of
like he checking swears he fives off
limits a one's probably off limits 95
that's a good move maybe he missed 95
ouch
whoa the king is gonna take some some
luck Ashwin's lost
oh no wait we just need half a point
like Katarina don't go crazy or maybe ox
I will flag wait let's look at the aqua
Ashwin game how do you lose a piece no
he went too crazy but I shot my flag the
bishop is trapped almost take the bishop
there's no mates right because the Queen
can check on beer then come back to g3
yes flag please flag he's not flagging
it's still complicated but maybe he can
just escape with some perpetual or take
on d4 good move he's winning nice I
least a draw
Queenie for hmm not necessary okay this
is looking good
Ashwin doing work hope weenie for just
simplifies and he wins b6
I wonder if oxide knows the score I got
shot has to play for a win we watch not
playing for a win the games are still
going like all three games still going
all we need is one draw Katarina still
up two pawns I like it Katarina beating
Shawn Nagle that's nice and the the
Tomas game whoa and rooting low on time
what is going on it's black just losing
probably that's sad 9f2 doesn't work he
plays it anyway
problem is Queen B 5 and then Queen to
e5 that's so sad
ouch Oh Queen c5 he's alive barely
kingi for what is going on the King's
gonna get mated right team g4 maybe this
is so scary
king h4 only move [ __ ] three Queen each
tribe mate well done to Andrew
so we lost that game two games left
oh this is scary uh a Schwinn can draw
this hopefully but it's not a gimme
lights probably better because all these
pawns are off limits from the bishop so
Catarina carrying it just needs a draw
be careful
please be careful she wins e6 should be
a draw
we'll stay on this game you just can't
let black heading get like some meeting
attack oh that was very good that she
took with night and not rook because
there is rook I think there is some work
check I don't know don't get meted
Koshka okay fair enough
he's playing on that's scary
oh no wait it's still okay right good
run keep running no it's gonna be broken
night versus this is annoying to watch
okay let's look at Ashwin she should
still draw this 15 moves she can claim
draw and move 125 if I can do math no
Ashwin's losing no katerina needs to
draw this for us to win otherwise a
matches a draw are you serious
this happened last week and white got
forked put the rook far away put the
Rick far away you need to survive till
move 120 good it's fine to repeat she
okay there is no Forex NightA for the
night was pin the night's still pins
don't get forks please miss Brooke H
yeah very fine keep checking it's fine
too
checking just gain time stay calm or
catch one good move always keep the rook
as far away as possible so it can
deliver checks and not get Forks just
keep checking game time um King okay
fine
this is so stressful to watch okay
very fine draw and move 124 she should
be aware of that
you got this Katarina be careful don't
put the King on the wrong square like
she I don't know and don't use all your
time either move the rook far away good
yeah good
pin good fine okay 100 we have 25 or 24
more removes just keep throwing the
checks you got this good about 20 more
moves this is tough like having 15
seconds left to second Crimmins rook a
one let's rotate one yeah okay fine yeah
as long as the rook stays far away so
stressful good move
fine she's threatening you're at 85 okay
keep the king somewhere yeah okay good
move
keep checking 10 more moose you can do
this don't get forked trade Brooks no 95
okay you're still doing fine you got
this okay fine keep the pin just keep
being patients
be careful be careful
ooh be very careful
yeah just keep checking from behind that
should last you just a few more moves
don't flag please don't flag rook e8
King f1 you good run kingi one just run
and then offer draw please offer a draw
you can claim it now just claim the draw
yes good job Katerina eight and a half
seven a half that was crazy that chat a
chest icon chat man nice job Katarina
pulled through other people slipped but
that was a huge team effort on 8.5 to
7.5 these numbers don't actually fit or
do they they do fit so the little last
round I don't even know what happened
Katerina drew oh she was up two pawns
though it's crazy Katarina drew Austrian
lost amaz lost limb one nice job
updating the scoreboard save that was
incredible and props to Minnesota that
was a really close match
we were the heavy favorite based on
reading but they put up a very tough
close fights okay
I'm ending it I'm sorry I would love to
stick around
look the games do other stuff
but I have to go I might be back later
I'll definitely be back tomorrow
stay tuned thanks to everyone for
watching shout out to Ilya who's still
in the chat and breathing and no
friction no friction I trained her well
okay uh yeah take care
adios and goodbye